[Musique]
elle a eu la troisième journée du forum
économique de saint-pétersbourg temps
forts la prise de parole de vladimir
poutine et plusieurs annonces à retenir
une volonté d'améliorer les relations
russo américaines dans le petit coeur
d'une rencontre avec joe biden la
réalisation la première ligne du gazoduc
north stream 2 reliant la russie à
l'allemagne et un appel aussi à la
vaccination nous ferons points dans un
instant d'ailleurs avec notre
spécialiste de l'économie sur place jean
marc sylvestre
[Musique]
toujours pas de réaction de la junte au
pouvoir au mali après la décision de la
france de suspendre l'opération barkan
sur le terrain emmanuel macron avait
averti c'est chose faite
la coopération entre les militaires
français et malien est à l'arrêt paris
reste dans la tente de garanties de la
part du colonel assimile golta désormais
au pouvoir à bamako après ces deux coups
d'état
[Musique]
et puis cette affaire qui secoue les
états unis les fossiles x il s'agit de
la publication de milliers de mails d'
anthony fauci à la tête de la cellule de
crise américaine contre le colis de 19
ce qui met le feu aux poudres des
échanges concernant l'origine du virus
les détails sont à suivre
dans cette édition
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france et au début de
ce journal avec le 24e forum économique
de saint-pétersbourg
[Musique]
au troisième jour de cette grande messe
internationale delà des murs poutine
s'est longuement exprimé sur les enjeux
de la relance économique et la lutte
contre la crise sanitaire revenus la
vaccination les investissements
étrangers
nord stream 2 les relations russo
américaines tout de suite ont rejoint
notre envoyé spécial à san pétersbourg
jean marc sylvestre
bonsoir jean marc alors qu retenir du
discours de vladimir poutine
bonsoir s'inventa et bien la lumière
poutine effectivement un exercice qui a
duré plus de trois heures et demie dans
lequel il s'est montré ferme dans ses
convictions dans son programme mais
assez prudent dans les modalités
d'application la lumière pour tir s'est
d'abord félicité de la tenue de ce forum
qui pouvait marquer pour la plupart des
russes la fin finalement de la pandémie
ou plutôt le début d'un commencement au
retour à la vie normale c'est vrai que
lorsqu'on voit la vie à ça à saint
pétersbourg on a vraiment le sentiment
que la vie a repris même si les mesures
de protection sanitaire sont appliquées
de façon stricte donc l'essentiel de son
propos et c'est intéressant a consisté à
s'adresser à trois populations
différentes il a commencé par s'adresser
à la population russe à son peuple si
vous venez en déroulant un programme de
soutien à l'activité économique
notamment en direction des catégories
les plus défavorisées ceux qui ont des
problèmes de l'eau
par exemple et puis il a déroulé un
programme de relance au niveau des pme
qui sont un peu comme en europe chez
nous créatrice d'emplois et qui ont
elles aussi souffert du comme la
deuxième cible de population à laquelle
il s'est adressé c'est l'opinion
publique internationale
en abordant la question de la politique
de santé qui doit être mondiale et
coordonnée et en abordant la politique
de vaccins qui ne sont pas encore
suffisamment diffusé notamment dans un
pays nombre de pays en difficulté alors
ce qui est intéressant c'est que c'est
que vladimir poutine a un peu taclé les
européens dans leur opposition pour
l'instant à utiliser le vaccin ce qui
n'a aucune raison scientifique victimes
mais que des raisons strictement
politique or la politique ne doit pas
rentrer en ordre de pont dans cette
affairé puis le troisième public c'est
sans doute celui qui était venu plus
spécialement forum économique de
saint-pétersbourg ce sont les
investisseurs et ce sont les entreprises
qui sont invités à collaborer à revenir
dans ce pays à collaborer à des grands
projets qui sont des projets
structurants et nécessaire pour
l'activité et notamment pour la mise en
place de ce nouveau monde en entre
guillemets alors à ce propos il a même
peut le révéler que le chantier
concernant nordstream vous le disiez
dans vos titres étaient achevés c'est
énorme canalisation qui traverse la
baltique qui va transporter le gaz des
côtes de russie jusqu'aux côtes
d'allemagne et qui va alimenter une
grande partie
de l'europe et qui suscite on le sait
bien un certain nombre de débats
politiques notamment en allemagne et en
général en europe et que répond vladimir
poutine justement aux critiques
politiques il à vis de ce chantier nord
stream 2
[Musique]
la vie meilleure pour qui le traite un
peu par l'humour il n'est pas n'est pas
du qui connaît les codes dans les
démocraties occidentales
il sait très bien qu'à des opinions
publiques à des courants politiques et
que la russie n'a pas forcément une très
bonne image dans certaines dans certains
de ces courants politiques mais de façon
très habile il a fait semblant
finalement de s'étonner que les
allemands écologistes notamment parce
que il s'agit principalement deux et
bien critique le gaz russe mais sont
prêts à acheter du gaz de schiste venant
d emma des américains venant d'amérique
le gaz russe est très sûrement beaucoup
moins cher il est très sûrement beaucoup
plus propre un coût beaucoup plus faible
et beaucoup moins polluant que les gaz
de schiste ce qui n'est pas contestable
il en va même jusqu'à suggérer que les
européens pourraient payer ce gaz en
euros et non pas en dollars comme on le
fait actuellement ce qui mettrait leur
approvisionnement complètement en
sécurité en cas de sanction sur les
monnaies c'est une des seules fois où il
abordera ces menaces de sanctions c'est
un discours qui doit plaire au chef
d'entreprise
alors justement aussi nahles que les
investisseurs les entreprises étrangères
se sont rassurés à l'issue de ce
discours
oui plutôt parce que vous savez les
investisseurs et des entreprises et
chefs d'entreprise ont besoin de
sécurité ils ont besoin de stabilité ils
ont besoin de transparence dans leurs
business donc tout ce qui participe à ce
pragmatisme
finalement le leur convient il y à des
pôles de difficultés avec l'amérique
avec leurs robes vladimir poutine
les connaît il n'a rien dit qui puisse
mettre de l'huile sur le feu sur ses
désaccords possible les entreprises
européennes ont besoin de la russie la
russie a besoin des technologies et une
expertise européenne parce que la russie
est un grand chantier et donc elle à l
intéresse beaucoup de monde c'est un
grand chantier c'est aussi la porte
ouverte sur l'asie alors les européens
n'ont qu'une inquiétude finalement dans
cette affaire celle de voir les russes
se tourner comme ils l'ont déjà un peu
fait vers la chine
si les conditions de travail qu'elles
soient juridiques fiscales aux
financières avec l'europe devenait plus
difficile donc les européens
investisseurs n'ont qu'un projet que le
politique ne vienne pas polluer le
climat des affaires
poutine a visiblement compris le message
est visiblement répondu à cette attente
dans l'essentiel de son discours on
verra d'ailleurs en juin et c'est ça qui
sera important si les choses évoluent
dans les faits et dans les actions
merci beaucoup à vous jean marc
sylvestre spécialiste de l'économie et
les questions aussi du business russe
aux africains justement invité au forum
firme à ingré bada le premier ministre
centrafricain et nous détaillent les
opportunités d'investissement dans son
pays je vous propose de l'écouter la
capitale centrafricaine
est un pays qui a beaucoup de
potentialités
e
je m'en vais vous citer quelques
exemples nous avons de l'or nous avons
du diamant nous avons aussi du bois ce
qui n'est pas insignifiant et d'allemand
nous avons une pile pluviométrie qui
nous permet de faire par exemple de
l'agriculture toute l'année c'est
important de participer donc à ce forum
économique de saint-pétersbourg pour que
dans une certaine diversité noticia
échanger avec tous les opérateurs
économiques avec les hommes d'affaires
du monde qui sont venus pour participer
donc à ce forum de manière à ce que nous
puissions donc leur présenter les
différentes opportunités qui s'offraient
à eux a notamment dans le monde des
affaires
donc les opportunités d'affaires
également des investissements directs en
république centrafricaine nous
travaillons sur l'amélioration du climat
des affaires
plus concrètement nous sommes en train
de faire en sorte que
notre appareil judiciaire donc puisse
garantir une véritable sécurité
juridique des affaires
nous travaillons également sur la
révision de la charte des
investissements de
également nous avons un instrument de
relèvements en matière économique qui se
trouve être le rcp sia qui donne donc
les grandes orientations en ce qui
concerne les réformes économiques et
dans ce cadre le général ce que nous
souhaitons c'est
le développement la promotion du secteur
privé pour qu'elle puisse donc donné
qu'ils puissent donner donc des grandes
opportunités d'emploi surtout pour nos
jeunes qui arrivent en nombre c'est sans
cesse pression sur le marché du travail
de façon à à lutter contre la pauvreté a
créé de la richesse donc
pour le développement du pays
[Musique]
oumali la junte au pouvoir est l'homme
fort du pays le colonel a subi gotha
n'ont toujours pas réglé la décision
française de suspendre l'opération
barkan à la décision d' emmanuel macron
est déjà effective sur le terrain
pour l'heure la coopération à des
militaires français avec les femmes à
l'armée malienne a cessé et les soldats
français pourront encore agir sol dans
le ciel paris attend des garanties pour
permettre le retour du pouvoir aux
civils on voit cela avec robin peine
paris met ses menaces à exécution
la suspension des opérations militaires
conjointes signifie que les 5100 hommes
de la force barkan n'effectueront plus
de manoeuvre avec l'armée malienne sur
le terrain les activités de la force
takouba censé former l'armée malienne en
combat face aux djihadistes sont
également suspendus cette décision
intervient en réaction au deuxième coup
d'état dans le pays en à peine neuf mois
le 24 mai dernier le président de la
transition et son premier ministre ont
été arrêtés par les hommes du colonel
keita puis contraint à la démission
ah si meego ita déjà à l'origine du
putsch contre ibrahim boubacar keïta en
ou 2020 et contre qui la communauté
internationale tente de faire pression
en vain face à cette énième crise qui
ébranle la stabilité au mali emmanuel
macron avait déjà laissé planer la
menace d'un retrait français ce jeudi le
ministère des armées a confirmé cette
décision
la france a décidé de suspendre à titre
conservatoire et temporaire les
opérations militaires conjointes avec
les forces maliennes ainsi que les
missions nationales de conseils à leur
profit ces décisions seront réévaluées
dans les jours à venir
au regard des réponses qui seront
fournies par les autorités maliennes
la france suit la dynamique initiée par
les etats-unis dont le département
d'état a suspendu dès la fin mai
l'assistance aux forces de sécurité et
de défense du mali en début de semaine
la cedeao a sanctionné le mali et
réclament le respect de la transition
démocratique
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement ont
condamné toutes les actions qui ont
conduit à cette situation d'instabilité
au mali et ses effets négatifs pour la
sous région après de longues discussions
sion les chefs d'état et de gouvernement
ont décidé de suspendre le mali des
institutions de la cedeao
conformément aux textes de
l'organisation malgré la multiplication
des sanctions le colonel assis meego ita
continue d'étendre son influence à
bamako la cour constitutionnelle
malienne l'a confirmé au poste de
président de la transition et il devrait
prêter serment d'ici le 7 juin prochain
et pour abd al khaimah koundougou me et
chercheur associé au groupe afrique de
l'institut prospective et sécurité de
l'europe il s'agit d'une décision de
paris plus politique que militaire
les crois que cette mesure même si
intervient dans un moment de tension
entre la france et les militaires au
mali
on a vu très bien que la macro a déjà
menacé plusieurs fois et a exigé le
retour à l'ordre constitutionnel
mais cette action n'est pas unilatérale
quand ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
l'armée française est là si c'est un
désengagement
dès lors que la france a décidé de ne
plus travailler avec l'armée malienne à
la femme doit retirer son armée du mali
mais si la france ne retire pas son
armée du mali et que si les militaires
au pouvoir
mais demandent pas le départ des
militaires français
'cela montre très bien que c'est plus
une décision politique qui mettrait la
pression sur une pression supplémentaire
sur le militaire afin de les obliger à
respecter le cahier de charge de la
transition en cours à bamako justement
il ya eu un rassemblement aujourd'hui
pour fêter le premier anniversaire du
mouvement du 5 juin
sur place de nombreux sympathisants du n
5 qui a contribué à la destitution du
président ibrahim boubacar keïta il
s'agit d'une plateforme qui regroupe des
mouvements de la société civile et des
politiques avec pour principal leader
l'imam dicko et cette plateforme elle
compte parmi aussi des soutiens au
colonel à signer golta l'homme fort
l'homme ou deux coups d'état
[Musique]
on en vient à cette affaire des faux
cils x qui fait grand bruit aux états
unis de quoi s'agit-il
des milliers d'e-mails envoyés et reçus
pendant plusieurs mois par anthony fauci
l'homme à la tête de la cellule de crise
des états unis face à l'épidémie de
covile 19 des échanges dévoilée par le
site d'information bolides et le
washington post les précisions c'est
avec notre reporter à washington thomas
bonnin des milliers de mails qui couvre
la première moitié de l'année 2020 et
donc l'émergence de la pandémie de
covile 19 il convient de rappeler qu'il
ne s'agit pas d'une fuite mais que les
médias buzzfeed le washington post ou
encore cnn on top tenu ses mails via le
freedom of information act une loi
américaine contraignant les agences
fédérales à transmettre certains
documents
beaucoup des changes ont été publiés il
ya environ dix mille mail mais une des
discussions qui a provoqué le plus de
réactions concerne anthony fochi et
peter d'assac le 18 et le 2020 anthony
faut que j'y reçois un message de ce
chercheur qui par le biais de sa
fondation a participé au financement de
recherches sur les coronavirus au sein
de l'institut de virologie de wuhan dans
ce mail
il remercie anthony frci d'avoir
publiquement pris position sur l'origine
du virus
je voulais simplement vous remercier
critiques d'avoir déclaré que les
preuves scientifiques soutiennent
l'origine naturelle du coc vide 19 par
transmission de la chauve souris à
l'homme et non une fuite d'un
laboratoire de l'institut de virologie
de roanne ce à quoi anthony fao çi a
répondu par un remercier mans certains
ont jugé cet échange comme une proximité
quelque peu déroutante entre le
scientifique de la maison blanche et sur
le chercheur ayant donc des liens avec
le laboratoire de one anthony fochi a
réagi sur l'antenne de cnn ces dernières
heures se défendant de tout lien avec le
scientifique en question en expliquant
qu'il pensait toujours que l'hypothèse
la plus probable est telle que le virus
était d'origine animale et que la fuite
d'un laboratoire n'était pas une piste
complètement écartée parmi les
correspondances dévoilé on retrouve
aussi le chef du conseil scientifique
français jean françois delfraissy
discussions qui date du 25 mars 2020
soit quelques jours après sa prise de
fonctions bon
jean françois delfraissy évoque
notamment je cite le buzz médiatique
depuis l'annoncé faite par le dr house
sur l'efficacité de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine dans la suite du mail chef
du conseil scientifique français
estiment que ces données ne sont pas
particulièrement convaincante
j'ai une énorme pression politique
explique-t-il pour libérer l'accès à
l'hydroxyethyl pour tout le monde et je
résiste actuellement faute chili a
répondu en expliquant que le président
donald trump fait également pression
pour prendre ses médicaments à des
cibles il ya évidemment beaucoup
d'autres choses qui sont abordés dans
les échanges de mails d'anthony fochi
comme par exemple sur le port du masque
qui n'encourageaient pas au mois de
février 2020 thaçi s'est expliqué hier
et affirmé que la situation de l'époque
était évidemment très différente que
celle qu'on connaît aujourd'hui après la
publication de ces mails et alors que le
sujet est parmi les plus commentés sur
les réseaux sociaux
la maison blanche a tenu à apporter son
soutien petit-fils soulignant je cite
son rôle incroyable dans la gestion de
la pandémie
et puis de son côté donald trump qui on
sait avait déjà eu des différends avec
anthony fulci a réagi également
affirmant que tout le monde désormais
commencer à dire qu'ils avaient raison
sur ce qu'il appelle le virus chinois
venant du laboratoire du rouane donald
trump qui souligne aussi qu'après avoir
vu ses emails je cite le pays est
chanceux que je n'ai pas fait tout ce
que docteur fochi voulez que je fasse un
facebook a suspendu pour deux ans les
comptes de donald trump une sanction
annoncée par communiqué elle entre dans
une stratégie plus strictes à l'égard
des responsables politiques
ces derniers seront désormais à
sanctionner comme n'importe quel autre
utilisateur et l'ex-président américain
réagit et dénonce une insulte à ses 75
millions d'électeurs une conférence de
presse déroulée à genève aujourd'hui
pour demander la libération immédiate de
julian assange
avec le soutien de reporters sans
frontières et de plusieurs personnalités
à le fondateur de wikileaks est toujours
placé en isolement dans une prison de
haute sécurité à londres et il fait
l'objet d'une demande d'extradition de
la part des états unis où il risque une
condamnation à 175 ans de prison pour
violation de la loi sur l'espionnage les
précisions avec mais rien
la règle il y avait une grande
détermination de tous les intervenants
beaucoup de personnalités étaient
présentes dont ils se mêlent their le
rapporteur spécial de l'onu sur la
torture
la maire de genève frédérique perler
genre aussi aux députés verts à
l'origine d'une résolution du parlement
genevois demandant à visa humanitaire
suisse pour julian assange est également
christophe deloire secret général de
reporters sans frontières qui a estimé
qu'à travers le cas assange et bien
c'était toute la profession
tous les tous les journalistes tous et
le droit à l'information qui était
menacée le moment le plus marquant de
cette conférence de presse a été
l'intervention de stella maurice la
compagne de julian assange beaucoup
d'émotion au moment de parler de ces
jeunes enfants qui n'ont pas vu leur
père depuis plusieurs mois on écoute la
compagne de julian assange julian n'a
pas vu ses enfants depuis le mois
d'octobre
lorsqu'il a été emmené en prison la
dernière fois que je les ai vus c'était
au tribunal le 6 janvier dernier quand
sa remise en liberté sous caution a été
refusée
je ne dis pas aux enfants que leur père
est en prison
ils n'ont aucune idée de ce qu'est une
prison parce que quand j'essaie de leur
expliquer je dois dire que c'est là que
vont les criminels là où les gens
mauvais vont parce qu'ils ont fait de
mauvaises choses et non pas là où les
gens bien se rendent pour avoir fait de
bonnes choses
beaucoup d'émotion donc pour stella
maury soutenue dans son combat par le
rapporteur spécial de l'onu sur la
torture ni le nerf qui se bat depuis
trois ans pour la libération d'assange
pour lui le cas est un pur scandale
il a notamment raconté comment lui même
a été trompé sur la paire à force on
écoute niels schneider
je suis allé voir julian assange après
que son premier avocat m'a contacté en
décembre 2018
il se trouvait encore à l'ambassade et
demander un mandat de protection ce que
j'ai refusé j'ai refusé intuitivement je
dis cela avec risque mais il est
important de le dire publiquement parce
que l'opinion publique
mondiale pense que julian assange est un
hacker un violeur un espion est un
traître
j'avais été influencé par ses discours
des médias son sujet de façon
inconsciente au point que j'étais trop
aveugle pour voir la réalité en face
je n'aurais pas même pris en charge son
dossier jusqu'à ce que ses avocats
viennent une deuxième fois avec un
certain nombre de preuves qui m'ont
permis d'ouvrir les yeux
c'est ce qui m'a conduit à lui rendre
visite avec deux médecins spécialisés
dans l'examen des victimes de torture
avec une expérience de 30 ans partout
dans le monde sans être influencé par
aucun titre à scandale les deux médecins
indépendamment en sont venus à la même
conclusion julian assange présente tous
les symptômes de torture psychologique
et j'ai eu la même impression lorsque je
lui ai parlé
il plaide pour qu au minimum d'eau les
ânes à sange soit mis en résidence
surveillée en attendant l'issue de
l'extradition car il ne peut pas selon
lui rester dans une prison de haute
sécurité à l'ombre en france a
maintenant 11 et 7 ans requis en appel
contre les deux ex qui n'aide accusé du
meurtre de clément méric mêmes peines
qu'en première instance le procès s'est
tenu toute l'après midi et le verdict il
est attendu ce soir les précisions avec
bassem chili depuis le tribunal d'evry
ch
une salle pleine dans le procès en appel
des deux meurtriers de clément méric
assassiné le 5 juin 2013 ce militant
anti fasciste s'est retrouvé au milieu
d'une rixe entre une bande de skinheads
et puis une bande d'antifascistes
c'était en juin 2013 aux alentours de
saint lazare la séance a commencé avec
différentes plaidoiries à commencer par
celle de l'avocat général qui est revenu
longuement sur les circonstances de
cette soirée cette soirée fatidique a
coûté l avis aux jeunes anti-fascistes
il est revenu également sur le profil
des deux prévenus à savoir samuel dufour
et ses bons mots rio il est revenu
également sur une intention au concret
de violence sur une intention concrètes
d'en découdre comme a dit l'avocat
général il a finit sa plaidoirie après
2h en s'adressant directement aux deux
accusés je cite j'ose espérer que depuis
ce drame vous avez pris des distances
avec cette idéologie est mortifère
mais aujourd'hui il faut rendre des
comptes à la société il a eu un mot
également l'avocat général sur ce que
voulait plaider de la défense à savoir
la légitime défense l'avocat général est
revenu sur l'autopsié du jeune
anti-fasciste aucune lésion de défense a
déclaré le médecin elle les jce ce qui
pousse l'avocat général a repoussé et
rejeter cette légitime défense
ensuite c'était au tour de l'avocat des
avocats de la défense qui ont plaidé
près de quatre heures pour samuel du
cours et pour rester devant mourinho je
vous propose d'écouter à ce sujet
l'avocat de samuel dufour nous sommes
étonnés d'avoir eu les mêmes
réquisitions en appel qu'en première
instance parce que la première instance
avait été extrêmement politique et
l'audience d'appel a été beaucoup plus
apaisé nous avons passé beaucoup de
temps sur les éléments du dossier il
nous semblait mais nous sommes en
défense que les éléments du dossier
pointé vers le fait que les skins ne
voulait pas la bagarre
il était d'ailleurs en infériorité
numérique ça s'est avéré qu'ils les
avaient peur au moment de sortir dans la
rue et
tout laisse à penser qu'ils se sont fait
tomber dessus et que malheureusement un
mauvais coup de poing entraîné le
déséquilibre puis le décès de clément
amérique c'est une vraiment c'est une
triste histoire
une triste histoire de bandes comme on
en voit régulièrement il s'avère que là
ce sont des bandes politiques parfois ce
sont des demandes qui sont sur une base
géographique
dans les deux cas c'est très malheureux
de voir un jeune homme de 19 ans perdre
la vie après plus de huit heures de
plaidoiries dans une salle comble place
aux délibérations l'avocat général
souhaite voir ces deux individus
condamnés pour violences volontaires en
réunion avec arme ayant entraîné l la
mort et l'au même réquisitoire qu'en
première instance à savoir sept ans de
prison pour samuel dufour et 11 ans de
prison pour esteban murillo le verdict
est attendu dans la nuit
dans moins de deux semaines les
élections à régional udi de xavier
bertrand souhaite se prolonger à la tête
des hauts de france et faire barrage au
rassemblement national écoutez le
vice-président dudit de la région daniel
leca je crois que les électeurs ont
besoin de clarté
ils ont besoin de transparence n'ont pas
envie de tambouille électorale d'accord
politicien et je crois que c'est ce que
nous avons fait nous dans les régions
des hauts de france avec une liste qui
sera la même au premier au second tour
et je crois sincèrement que les
électeurs n'accepte plus n'aime n'aime
pas les consignes de vote il faut
aujourd'hui être clair sur c'est sûr
c'est sur ses convictions et nous
l'avons toujours dit nous sommes
évidemment pour qu' aucune région de
bascule au front national et ça implique
évidemment que chacun des candidats
soient responsables en fonction de la
position qui est la sienne au soir du
premier tour de prendre une décision qui
soit responsable qui ne crée pas de
confusion dans les idées il craint pas
de confusion dans les valeurs que l'on
défend
mais qu'ils soient claires notamment
dans le barrage au front national il ya
aujourd'hui besoin je crois pour la
région de france de continuer le travail
que nous avons engagé de dynamisation
nous avons permis de faire reculer le
front du chômage nous battons
aujourd'hui pour la santé des habitants
pour la sécurité des habitants
nous avons pour nous un bilan un bilan
positif qui a montré que nous nous
sommes battus nous avons obtenu des
résultats et que c'est sur cette lancée
que nous voulons évidemment continuer et
nous nous inscrivons pleinement dans une
démarche
qui vise à poursuivre le travail engagé
en accélérant notamment je le disais
autour de thématiques comme la santé
comme la sécurité comme l'emploi et ce
sont des priorités absolues pour gagner
pour la liste qui l'entourent et c'est
la fin de cette édition merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi on va se retrouver dans 30
minutes avec un autre débat autour du
nouveau projet d'impôt mondial des
entreprises deux invités jean marie
harribey membres des économistes
atterrés et philippe béchade rédacteur
en chef de la bourse au quotidien rester
avec nous sur rt france à total
[Musique]
le terme banlieue voir le terme cité
c'est forcément péjoratif c'est vrai que
les médias ont un regard on va dire
assez particulier des banlieues et qui
dérange aujourd'hui et on donne cette
impression de la banlieue ça se
résoudrait cas des jeunes violents
contre une police tout ce qu'elle son
travail c'est plus compliqué que ça on
est français on est fiers de vivre dans
ces quartiers même s'il ya des
difficultés est la moindre des choses
c'est d'inscrire aussi notre empreinte
canton quand on participe à la vie de la
société et malheureusement il n'y a pas
cette reconnaissance
aujourd'hui je pense que le changement
viendra d'abord à travers cette
conscientisation des citoyens des
quartiers populaires on parle également
des deux zones de reconquête
républicaine
au final derrière ces mots qu'est ce qui
casse qui se cachent des politiques font
pour les gens mais sans les gens c'est à
dire qui donne cette impression de faire
de vouloir changer les choses mais
concrètement politiquement ils ne le
font pas
bienvenue à novossibirsk heures nous
sommes au bord de la volga le plus long
fleuve d'europe nous sommes